economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio jorge hurtado de nicaragua para
el mundo está con nosotros para comenzar
a hablar de esos detalles jorge de la
reunión de la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
que dijera bueno la tributación global a
grandes compañías quedaría en 15 por
ciento durante el encuentro de la ocde
una nueva versión del texto que van a
discutir para reformar la tributación
internacional ya no menciona una tasa
impositiva corporativa global de al
menos el 15 por ciento sino del 15 por
ciento según varias fuentes 140 países
se reunirán este viernes en parís para
finalizar esta ambiciosa reforma
destinada a gravar aún más a las
empresas multinacionales y esperan que
sea respaldada por el g20 a finales de
este mes hasta ahora santiago 134 de los
140 países involucrados en las
negociaciones apoyan una tasa impositiva
corporativa global de al menos el 15 por
ciento pero hay un detalle de irlanda
donde se encuentran muchas
multinacionales debido a su baja tasa
impositiva se negó a participar a
participar temiendo que la tasa quede
por encima del 15% no le conviene para
su economía porque hablemos ya que
estamos hablando de economía global
hablemos que se espera otro informe pero
esta vez del fondo
monetariointernacional khedira bueno las
previsiones santiago de crecimiento
global para 2021 que el fm iba a
presentar la próxima semana en el marco
de su asamblea anual junto con el banco
mundial serán menores del 6 por ciento
así lo dijo la gerente del fmi y
kristalina georgieva según ella la
economía mundial aún cojea por la crisis
que provocó la pandemia de coronavirus
la funcionaria comentó que eeuu y china
continúan como los motores vitales de
crecimiento aunque ese impulso t se está
ralentizando y añadió que europa y
algunas economías emergentes todavía
mantienen un repunte notable durante una
intervención en italia la funcionaria
del fmi destacó como principales
obstáculos a la reactivación económica
la divergencia entre la vacunación en
países avanzados y en desarrollo el
repunte de la inflación y la elevada
carga de la deuda usted nos mencionaba
que eeuu la economía se está
ralentizando que detalles hay de la
economía de este país
bueno en ese país el déficit comercial
aumentó a un récord de 7 mil 300
millones de dólares en agosto según el
departamento de comercio los nuevos
datos muestran que el déficit comercial
mensual aumentó un 42 por ciento en
agosto llegando a un máximo histórico y
superando el récord anterior de 73 mil
200 millones establecido en junio en
agosto las exportaciones aumentaron un
0,5 por ciento y se situó en 213 mil 700
millones de dólares esto es un reflejo
de la reactivación de la demanda
exterior pero las importaciones e
incluso con los problemas de la cadena
de suministro en los puertos aumentaron
un 1,4 por ciento y se ubicó en 287 mil
millones el déficit comercial santiago
representa la brecha entre lo que el
país exporta al resto del mundo y las
importaciones que compra de otros países
analistas esperan que el aumento del
déficit comience a disminuir con otras
economías reactivándose sin embargo
algunos advierten que los problemas en
la cadena de suministros globales
podrían afectar tanto a las
exportaciones como las importaciones en
los próximos meses tienen el panorama de
la economía de eeuu hablemos ahora de la
red de la frontera común entre colombia
y venezuela detalles de este tema jorge
bueno santiago al abrirse los
principales pasos fronterizos entre
colombia y venezuela hay quienes esperan
una reactivación comercial entre ambos
países pero hay mucho camino para
retornar a los números de antes y vamos
a ellos por ejemplo en 2014 antes del
cierre de las fronteras el intercambio
comercial entre colombia y venezuela
acumuló 2.427 millones de dólares
después llegó la crisis y la cifra que
ayuda a casi la mitad en 2015 para
quedar en mínimos durante los siguientes
años la relación comercial de ambos
países ha sido de altibajos
históricamente pero el crecimiento más
importante se produjo entre 2004 y 2009
hace 14 años santiago la federación
nacional de comerciantes de colombia
fenalco reportó un vínculo económico de
unos 7 mil 290 millones de dólares entre
ambos países entonces venezuela del
segundo socio comercial de colombia pero
el deterioro de las relaciones llevó a
que en 2020 la cifra cayera en 130
millones de dólares son fronteras muy
activa pese a los altibajos indicadores
como las ffaa las bolsas en la jornada
hoy wall street cerró este martes con
ganancias tras el periodo negativo de
septiembre un mes que tradicionalmente
es débil pero al que se sumaron factores
como la política monetaria y la crisis
del gigante chino de bertrand en europa
la bolsa cerraron en positivo animada
por wall street y en américa latina
siguió de lejos la estela positiva de
wall street y el resto de los mercados
internacionales y para el cierre la
cifra del día sorprenda los 70 millones
de usuarios ganó la aplicación de
mensajería telegram durante las
interrupciones de whatsapp facebook e
instagram luego nos cuenta si usted
escribió muchas gracias jorge es todo
por el momento ya viene el debate en
france 24 siga con nosotros
[Música]